Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
Whenever we take an image with our camera,
and look at it after an event, we often feel
that many of them are close to perfect, if
only it was less blurry, or the focus distance
was a bit further away.
But the magic moment is now gone, and there
is nothing to do other than cursing at the
blurry footage that we're left with when showing
it to our friends.
However, if we have access to light fields,
we can change some camera parameters after
the photo was taken.
This includes changing the focal distance,
or even slightly adjusting the viewpoint of
the camera.
How cool is that!
This can be accomplished by a light field
camera which is also referred to as a plenoptic
camera.
This tries to record not only light intensities,
but the direction of incoming light as well.
Earlier, this was typically achieved by using
an array of cameras.
That's both expensive and cumbersome.
And here comes the problem with using only
one light field camera: because of the increased
amount of data that they have to record, current
light field cameras are only able to take
3 frames per second.
That's hardly satisfying if we wish to do
this sort of post-editing for videos.
This work offers a novel technique to remedy
this situation by attaching a standard camera
to this light field camera.
The goal is that the standard camera has 30,
so tons of frames per second, but with little
additional information, and the light field
camera, which has only a few frames per second,
but, with a ton of additional information.
If we stitch all this information together
in a smart way, maybe it is a possibility
to get full light field editing for videos.
Earlier, we have talked about interpolation
techniques that can fill some of the missing
frames in videos.
This way, we can fill in maybe every other
frame in a footage, or we can be a bit more
generous than that.
However, if we're shown 3 frames a second,
and we have to create a smooth video by filling
the blanks would almost be like asking an
algorithm to create a movie from a comic book.
This would be awesome, but we're not there
yet.
Too much information is missing.
This stitching process works with a bit more
information than this, and the key idea is
to use two convolutional neural networks to
fill in the blanks: one is used to predict
flows, which describe the movements and rotations
of the objects in the scene, and one to predict
the final appearance of the objects.
Basically, one for how they move, and one
for how they look.
And the results are just absolutely incredible.
It is also blazing fast and takes less than
a tenth of a second to create one of these
new views.
Here, you can see how the final program is
able to change the focal distance of any of
the frames in our video, or we can even click
on something in the image to get it in focus.
And all this is done after the video has been
taken.
The source code of this project is also available.
With some more improvements, this could be
tremendously useful in the film industry,
because the directors could adjust their scenes
after the shooting, and not just sigh over
the inaccuracies and missed opportunities.
And this is just one of many possible other
applications.
Absolutely amazing.
If you enjoyed this episode, don't forget
to subscribe to Two Minute Papers and also
make sure to click the bell icon to never
miss an episode.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!